من
[موسيقى]
المواطنين طبعا طائره الكواد كابتر وطائره
الاستطلاع فستشهد عددا
[موسيقى]
منهم هنا محاوله بعض
الناس
النازحين العوده الى منازلهم في مخيم
البريج
في ظل الحديث عن انسحاب قوات الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي
من
احد المحاو في مخيم البريج وهنا حجم
الدمار طبعا دمار واسع في المخيم لا احد
في الشوارع
نتيجه القصف الاسرائيلي والتوغل في مخيم
البريج نحن الان على مقربه من
دوار
دعابس المعروف في مخيم البريج وهنا اصوات
اطلاق النار
لازالت حاضره هنا الان نحن على
مقربه ومن اماب مدرسه بوابه ابو هميسه
والمواطنون بداوا يعودون الى هذه
المدرسه طبعا المواطنون نازحون من مخيم
البريج الان هنا نحن على بوابه مدرسه ابو
هميسه ندخل
اليها هناك المدرسه طبعا بعض المواطنين
فيها اجت الوكاله بلغونا انه البريج
مربع عسكري مغلق يعني ممنو حد يخشه ما
بيجيب لنا هنا فيش عننا حاجه احنا هنا
محاصرين هان ميه فيشي ممنوع ح اللي بيطلع
بطخ يعني قبل شويه امبارح في الليل شهدين
على الباب عبرنا احنا ط هان على المدخل
بعد بشوي طلعناهم على عربيه زق الحمد لله
احنا بالنسبه لنا بدع المقاومه وبنقول لها
شدي حيلك واحنا معاك واحنا من الصامدين
واحنا بالنسبه لنا مش هنسيب الارض ولا
هنسيب الوطن قاعدين يا ام يا
احنا